[Music]
the cosmos can be a dangerous place take
black holes for example there are some
of the most violent objects in our
universe powerful enough to rip entire
stars to pieces their secret weapon is
gravity you see the more mass you can
shrink into a small space
the stronger your gravitational force
will become to make earth into a black
hole for instance you'd have to shrink
it to less than an inch across the real
black holes are much larger than that
and pack way more mass than Earth here's
just how big black holes can really get
there are three common types of black
holes the smallest are stellar black
holes which form after a giant star
explodes and collapses in on itself like
this one which measures about 40 miles
across roughly three times the length of
Manhattan but in that small space is
enough mass to equal eleven of our Suns
in another galaxy called m33 there's a
black hole that is 58 miles across and
packs as much mass as 15.7 Suns inside
up next are the intermediate mass black
holes like this one at 1400 and 60 miles
across
it's nearly large enough to stretch from
Florida to Maine and according to some
calculations contains the mass of four
hundred Suns at this point black holes
start to get pretty big compared to
Earth but it's still nothing when you
consider the sheer mass they carry take
this black hole for example it's nearly
twice the size of Jupiter spanning a
region about one hundred and seventy two
thousand miles wide but inside is as
much mass as forty-seven thousand suns
but these black holes are nothing
compared to supermassive black holes
like Sagittarius a star which
the center of our Milky Way galaxy it
covers a region about fourteen point six
million miles in diameter
that's roughly 168 Jupiter's across and
inside is the same amount of mass as
four million Suns combined now that may
sound big
but Sagittarius a star is small compared
to other supermassive black holes take
the one at the center of our neighbor
the Andromeda galaxy which has a
diameter of 516 million miles larger
than Jupiter's orbit and contains enough
mass to equal that of 140 million Suns
we're finally getting to some of the
largest black holes in the universe and
yet we haven't reached one that
surpasses the size of our solar system
so let's look at the supermassive black
hole at the center of the sombrero
galaxy it measures 2 billion miles
across so it would stretch further than
Uranus's orbit and it has about the same
mass as 660 million Suns and the
supermassive black hole at the center of
Messier 87 is so huge that astronomers
could see it from 55 million light years
away
it's 24 billion miles across and
contains the same mass as six and a half
billion suns
but this supermassive black hole as
large as it is could still fit within
our solar system with plenty of room to
spare so we have to look at one of the
most massive of all supermassive black
holes it has a diameter of about 78
billion miles for perspective that's
about 40% the size of our solar system
according to some estimates
it is estimated to be about 21 billion
times the mass of our Sun so there you
have it black holes can be millions of
times larger than suns and planets or as
small as a city it all depends on how
much mass is inside turns out when it
comes to the cosmos size isn't the only
thing that matters